[Musique]
j'ai eu envie de dessiner comment je me
sentais la fausse couche est une réalité
méconnue même tabou bien qu'elle touche
en moyenne une grossesse sur cinq j'ai
décidé d'écrire comment je n'ai vécu que
j'ai partagé puis je me serais jamais
attendu à cette réaction la
musicienne et chanteuse du groupe raffy
caroline filaient le parfait bonheur
avec son amoureux depuis 13 ans ça
allait super bien le film de disney par
excellence on se marie on s'achète une
maison et un petit big s'en vient
enceinte de trois mois leur projet de
fonder une famille s'effondre et un soir
sur scène j'étais en train de chanter
puis comment ça va vraiment des grosses
douleurs au vent et le lendemain ben
vont chez le médecin il temps d'écouter
coeur du bébé l'entend pas
on ne fait un petit mausolée pour pour
les bides véronique a fait sa fausse
couche il y a quelques semaines à peine
son conjoint et elle ont vécu cette
épreuve entourés de leurs deux garçons
un moment marquant dans sa vie on pense
jamais que ça peut nous arriver
après la tristesse et l'incompréhension
le silence et la culpabilité s'installe
c'est un peu aussi pour ce que c'est
c'est abouti les gens ils en parlent peu
parce que ça peut être gênante sans
vraiment vide sans honte eux aussi ces
places je sais qu'il avait pas de honte
a ressenti mais tu la ressens c'est donc
leur gros sentiment d'échec et c'est pas
trés quelques jours qu'on se remet de la
perte d'un enfant julie charbonneau
anime des cafés causeries à l'organisme
parents orphelins la femme qui a perdu
quatre bébés durant ces grossesses est
très bien placé pour accompagner les
familles qui vivent un deuil c'est un
processus un cheminement c'est une
réadaptation en soit le deuil périnatal
[Musique]
une démarche dans laquelle caroline et
son conjoint se sont sentis bien seuls
j'ai trouvé qu'il ya eu vraiment un gros
manque c'est comme envoyer chez moi
samedi c'était quoi la suite donc moi
bon ton bébé mort tu fait une fausse
couche bonne chance
il ya beaucoup ne sont pas au courant de
ces ressources et camille baheux
accompagne des couples dans l' aventure
de la parentalité lorsqu'une fausse
couche survient elle oriente les parents
vers le soutien approprié c'est épuisant
au départ quand on le sait qu'on veut
c'est butés à un manque de ressources
clsc maison de la famille des lieux où
les couples endeuillé peuvent trouver de
l'écouté du réconfort il faut comme
tomber sur la bonne infirmière qui va
être capable des données comme la liste
de toutes les ressources mais ça demeure
malgré tout banalisée par les
professionnels de la santé par les gens
souvent de l'entourage et par les
employeurs malheureusement
au travail comme si de rien n'était
la routine et les obligations du
quotidien ont rapidement rattrapé
véronique même si tu vis une fausse
couche avant 20 semaines si peu avant un
programme niveau de la psychologie qu
sinon au niveau professionnel c'est
d'avoir poussé plus de mesures
conciliation famille travail idéalement
on vivrait dans une société où dès qu'on
est résultats positifs on peut se
permettre la joie de le partager avec
les gens autour de nous puis 6 quelques
semaines après malheureusement on perd
notre bébé qu'on puisse en parler aussi
piqué ça soit accueilli de la bonne
façon que notre employeur nous
permettent de prendre de prendre deux
semaines de congé depuis que les
véhicules ja j'ai appris tellement
d'histoires de gens de deux mois que
j'aurais jamais pensé pour briser le
tabou caroline pense que le risque de
fausse couche devrait être abordée dès
le premier suivi médical des quelques
uns pensent avoir un enfant en parler
expliqué que cc c'est une possibilité
malheureusement mon - la personne a pu
se préparer à ça qui a poussé à moins
d'attendre et plus que tout elle
aimerait qu'on cesse de mettre 2 la
pression sur les couples demandé un
copain et ça fait longtemps que vous
êtes ensemble car les enfants peut-être
qu'ils en veulent peau peut-être qu'ils
ont essayé puis que ça marche peut-être
qu'ils viennent d'en perdre parce que
c'est vraiment une question qui fait mal
donc aujourd'hui on boucle un peu la
boucle c'est à dire que je vais à la
clinique pour vous dire fils tout est
beau véronique souhaite que son histoire
inspire plusieurs femmes à briser le
silence entourant la fausse couche pour
pouvoir tourner la page puis puis
peut-être test s'est à nouveau quant à
caroline son conjoint et elle ont
toujours le souhait de fonder une
famille
et ça on en a beaucoup parlé je pense qu
on leur dirait on le regretterait de ne
pas avoir d'enfants
[Musique]